bienvenidos de vuelta haré otro problema
sobre conservación de energía pero esta
vez agregaré un cambio hasta ahora la
energía total era la misma por la ley de
la conservación pero eso es porque todas
las fuerzas las fuerzas que actuaban
eran fuerzas conservativa
ahora vamos a introducir un poco de
fricción y veremos que una parte de la
energía se va a perder en esa fricción y
podemos pensar un poco más sobre esto
porque por ejemplo si se pierde a dónde
va esa energía así que este ejercicio
que voy a poner en este momento lo
obtuve de la universidad de oregon de
oregón y la página es zeb1 punto y
oregón
punto edu ok que parece que tienen muy
buenos problemas de física así que voy a
usarlos y solo quería asegurarme de que
de que tengan el crédito que merecen muy
bien entonces el problema nos dice que
tenemos un una una bicicleta y un
ciclista ok que tienen una masa
90 kilogramos en conjunto ok se
encuentran en reposo sobre una colina
entonces no sé digamos que ésta es
nuestra colina
muy bien ahí tienen ustedes una colina
quizás debería pintarla más o menos
pronunciada
algo así ahí tienen ustedes una colina
nos dicen además que esta colina tiene
500 metros como ladera muy bien digamos
la longitud de esta ladera desde 500
metros y tiene una inclinación de 5
grados muy bien entonces no sé más o
menos a lo mejor así se ve esta colina
vamos a quitarle un poquito de este
excedente muy bien y nos dice que aquí
está un ciclista no sé nunca he pintado
una bicicleta y menos con
un personaje arriba tengo amigos que
podrían pintarlo muy bien
más o menos muy bien y tenemos a nuestro
ciclista verdad que está ahí conduciendo
esta bici muy bien ahí tenemos nuestra
bicicleta y la colina muy bien entonces
ya que tenemos esto vamos a suponer que
tenemos una fuerza de fricción promedio
de 60 newtons muy bien tenemos una
fuerza de fricción de 60 newtons vamos a
ponerlo aquí una fuerza de fricción de
60 newtons y recordemos que la fuerza de
fricción siempre actúa en dirección
contraria al movimiento que en este caso
pues será colina abajo muy bien entonces
la pregunta que nos hacen es cómo
podemos hallar la velocidad al pie de la
colina es decir cuando esté este
personaje ya está en el pie de la colina
cuál es su velocidad y definitivamente
este es un problema de conservación de
energía muy bien entonces si vamos a
tratar de utilizar esto podríamos
intentar ver cuál es la energía
potencial que tiene este
al inicio entonces la energía potencial
recordemos que es la masa por la
aceleración debido a la gravedad por la
altura verdad sin embargo nosotros no
conocemos cuál es la altura de esta
colina así que vamos a tener que hacer
uso de un poco de trigonometría muy bien
entonces aquí esta es la altura que
queremos conocer y eso lo podemos saber
porque sabemos cuánto mide la hipotenusa
de este triángulo que es la colina y
sabemos cuánto mide el ángulo de
inclinación entonces sabemos que el seno
de 5 grados es justamente la altura que
es el cateto opuesto dividido entre la
hipotenusa que mide 500 muy bien
entonces la altura simplemente será 500
por el seno de 5 grados y sólo hay que
calcular cuánto vale el seno de 5 grados
entonces voy a sacar la calculadora y
vamos a calcular el seno de 5 que es 0
puntos 0 87 que entonces esto sería algo
así como 500 x 0.0 87 si eres el punto
ok
ahí está bien y cuánto nos da esto si
esto si esto anterior lo multiplicamos
por 500 que nos da
nos da 43.6 digamos redondeado esto es
más o menos 43.6 y la altura se mide en
metros así que ya tenemos esta altura
que es de 43.6 metros así que la energía
potencial será la masa que es 90
kilogramos por la aceleración
vamos a ponerlo no sé cómo la con morado
que son 9.81 metros sobre segundo
cuadrado por la altura que ya vimos
cuánto es que son 43 puntos 6 metros
entonces kilogramos metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado nos da newtons por metro nos
da
jules bien entonces esto será algo que
está en jules entonces tenemos aquí esto
que multiplicado
punto 8 vamos a dejarlo solo como 9.8
nos da este número que es 427 puntos 0 6
y si multiplicamos por 90 que es la masa
nos da 38 43
déjenme ver
déjenme verificar que a 43.6 a claves
que me salio distinto porque aquí era
43.6 y yo no hice se redondee entonces a
ver 43.6 por 9.8 9.8 vamos a dejarlo así
por 90 eso nos da 38 45 538 mil 400 55
38 mil 455 jules el otro número era más
exacto pero vamos a dejarlo así
utilizando este redondeo muy bien
entonces esta cantidad de energía es
muchísima es son muchos dulces mucha
energía y todo esto cuando llega al
final será que todo esto se convierte en
energía cinética pues casi lo que pasa
es que aquí ya tenemos una fuerza de
fricción y que la fuerza de fricción lo
puedes pensar como que es una fuerza que
se come de alguna forma la energía
mecánica es como es una fuerza no
conservativa ahora como vamos a ver esto
lo podemos ver de lo siguiente la
energía inicial la energía que teníamos
al inicio del problema pues
esencialmente es lo que voy a tener al
final y además lo que se pierde por la
fricción entonces va a ser la energía la
energía perdida digamos la energía
perdida por fricción por fricción más la
energía que nos queda al final más la
energía final muy bien vamos a dejarlo
así el más la energía final entonces si
uno piensa que la energía perdida por
fricción es un número negativo en
realidad lo podemos escribir esto como
como que tenemos nuestra energía inicial
y si le sumamos la energía perdida por
fricción que que vamos a ponerlo así es
wv efe que es el trabajo generado por la
fricción y voy a suponer que este número
es negativo que esto sería igual a la
energía final a la energía final muy
bien ahora que tenemos
nosotros conocemos cuál es nuestra
energía inicial verdad son 38 mil 455
jules vamos a vamos a escribirlo en
corto como 38.5 kilo jules verdad más el
trabajo generado por esta fuerza de
fricción que va a ser un número negativo
y recordemos que el trabajo no es otra
cosa más que fuerza por distancia así
que esto va a ser menos 60 por 500 que
es nuestra distancia verdad si nosotros
y nuestra bici se está moviendo en esta
dirección entonces la fricción tiene que
ir en esta otra dirección que es
justamente la dirección contraria al
movimiento que entonces tenemos menos 60
por 500 esto nos va a dar la energía
final ahora bien esto es algo muy fácil
de calcular porque tenemos que 60 por
500 son 30.000 y aquí tenemos 38 mil 455
así que si hacemos 38 mil 455
30.000 nos quedan simplemente que la
energía final es igual a 8 mil 455 jules
muy bien y esto es la energía final que
es un medio de la masa por la velocidad
al cuadrado así que podemos calcular la
velocidad que tenía al final de todo
esto verdad porque sí
el 2 bueno la masa es de 90 si dividimos
entre 245 así que si hacemos 8.455
entre 45 nos da 187 punto 19 digamos muy
bien aquí tendríamos 45 dividimos entre
45 de ambos lados y nos da que leen la
velocidad al cuadrado más bien es
velocidad
y aquí tenemos que la velocidad al
cuadrado era 187.925 87.9 y podemos
concluir si sacamos la raíz cuadrada de
esto que es 13.7 verdad entonces la
velocidad es igual a 13.7 metros sobre
el segundo muy bien y aquí es
esencialmente lo que teníamos es un
problema de conservación de la energía
no no estamos diciendo que no hay
pérdida de energía solo estamos diciendo
que la energía que teníamos al inicio es
el justo la energía que se pierde más la
energía que tiene nuestro ciclista al
final muy bien y esto lo podemos
resolver esencialmente con un poquito de
trigonometría y unas operaciones
aritméticas muy sencillas así que lo uno
podría ponerse a pensar bueno si la
energía no se pierde ni se crea sino
sólo se transforma entonces que le está
pasando a esta energía que se pierde en
la fricción y esto esencialmente se está
convirtiendo en
o más bien lo que está haciendo es que
se genere como calor por ejemplo si tú
te deslizas en una lija oa lo mejor si
te has aventado en una alfombra puedes
notar que a veces cuando roza el
pantalón con la lija o con la alfombra
entonces el pantalón se calienta esto
nos está diciendo de adónde se va toda
esa energía
por debido a la fricción verdad puede
ser que a lo mejor en este caso de la
bici esa fricción se esté generando no
sé a lo mejor por los mismos las llantas
oa lo mejor algunas tuercas que no estén
bien puestas qué sé yo
el viento no sé pero bueno espero que te
haya parecido interesante este problema
ahora no sólo sabes la ley de la
conservación de la energía sino también
sabe resolver un problema con un poco de
fricción nos vemos en el próximo vídeo